central you see citizens wrong before
what's wrong for what kind of theme is
this residual do it works out
approximations of what a stranger
awkward areas that don't fit like Eric
triangle average babies etc maybe just
on the side just to jog your memory
enjoy yourself one of these something
like like that
so here the classic enable something
like a summer music program movie like
so so here is organ area and you've got
all of these measurements on here that
we can provide to you I'm not interested
in the numbers but you might know this
makes dis length this length this length
of this leg what's the other business
mission usually produce substantial
apart from these guns you want to do it
yeah very good this common disparate
scheme they've all got me to save do you
remember that we have a letter them
usually a photograph we usually call H
which is on it stands for high even
though sideways but a shake can be
oriented whichever way you like through
now I wonder if you remember again you
don't have to but it's helpful to do you
remember the formula for citizens rule
Nick Goepper
H over three times
what we called cool yep okay for the end
now this is the scissors rule that you
find on the formula sheet you can see
like you told me there's this like here
then you've got one two three values
hold on a second though is particularly
if a budget it and give you three one
two three
I gave you five so what would you do
with this particular you see this before
you would and that's the actual phrase
that they use use two applications of
Simpsons rule to approximate this area
so you would do this once for this shape
over here there you go see one two three
dollars and then you were doing the
second time and this check over here
which means that if you have a look at
the middle is purpley bit here you use
this value either twice right for the
blue area if the last and for the red
area for first so you're seeing this
before okay however one of the great
things that this is rule and then you
can actually use it for a lot more than
just area let's commit some extra doctor
if you picture what you're looking at
here and sort of like a are a
cross-section of like a riverbed okay so
what you've got is a really major
changes in width and in depth at
different places like a normal River
there does okay now if what you've got
here it lengths that are consistent just
like you had over here
if its stead of knowing what these waves
are you had these cross-sectional areas
you can use since Israel in exactly the
same way so again just like we had
before I'm just going to make up some of
this if these are area if it's a
riverbed I guess we're looking at some
Square cheaters that'll be a medium we
unit square centimeters of inch in small
quick one is easy to big so I'm going to
call this one say a hundred square
meters if that's a hundred square meters
won't you definitions just give you a
rough ballpark how many of these it is
then
that's how many 15 8 10 I reckon I think
it's pretty close
let's make it out anything is done
Kennedy there's get to there don't
forget this is my Camaro [ __ ] as well
oh yeah this see fitting into this
middle area to cross-section Mike
insisted a lot of prisons over there
well I'm just going to make it on my
left toilet you're all disagrees I'm
going to call it that that's somewhere
to drink whatever thing and then you've
got one life area on the air letters
crawled at me so it is what we're
calculating now is not an area you can
still use sisters you're in much the
same way we've got the consistent height
you've got these they call function
values now then do longer links and I
can use this formula just like I did
before
oh we need one more thing this is over
here let's call this employee now
remember there has been same what I mean
consistent all the way through so now I
can say an approximation of the volume
volume is approximately equals equal to
and what is this all just like I did
before so here's my H these are my HS
how do you know whether the VHS or the
images because the formula sheet tours
you've got a bench the honey wagon about
your fringe another man it's the same
it's consistent and you can sort of see
that you see how it only appears once so
you don't need to do it over and over
again if these were they are pages that
you put in the same number repeatedly
that's input so I'm going to take 80 on
three and then I've got these values
that come in the middle so this is going
to be 100 square meters fourth of this
setting middle one and now just as
you're finishing writing that out and
maybe getting your calculator apps start
evaluating that I just want to make a
point which came home in Balad the game
you just did in the 83 you
a heck of a lot of conversions to do
right this just happens all the time you
get given units you calculate something
you're like that means units are no
longer in good my number is enormous
well my number is tiny I'd better
convert or sometimes you ask for a cost
for a coin so conversion should happen
so that mean there's more and more I'm
going to encourage you to write units
every single time I know from early on
you might have gotten to the house just
writing the numbers and adding the units
of the very out in most cases that'll
get you fun but a lot of you got really
confused because you changed unit along
the way we didn't say what you're doing
so I'm going to write every line from
now on someone got a number for me 1969
two to zero
yeah for you nine to 256 I did know some
questions yes big seven do you want to
write it off so what's really do want
you that's when you make a DC mean is
you kidding
very good so you notice we traditional
in the leg oh that was money
I forgot the unit then here's a leg
times an area that gives you a volume
right